we now introduce normal random variables
which are also often called Gaussian
random variables normal random variables
are perhaps the most important ones in
probability theory they play a key role
in the theory of the subject as we will
see later in this class in the context
of the central limit theorem
they are also prevalent in applications
for two reasons they have some nice
analytical properties and they are also
the most common model of random noise in
general they are a good model of noise
or randomness whenever that noise is due
to the addition of many small
independent noise terms and this is a
very common situation in the real world
we define normal random variables by
specifying their PDFs and we start with
the simplest case of the so called
standard normal the standard normal is
indicated with this shorthand notation
and we will see shortly why this
notation is being used it is defined in
terms of a PDF this PDF is defined for
all values of X X can be any real number
so this random variable takes values can
take values anywhere on the real line
and the formula for the PDF is this one
let us try to understand this formula so
we have the exponential of negative x
squared over 2 now if we are to plot the
x squared over 2 function it has a shape
of this form and it is centered at 0 but
then we take the negative exponential of
this function now when you take the
negative exponential whenever this thing
is big the negative exponential is going
to be small so the negative exponential
would be equal to 1 when X is equal to 0
but then as x increases because x
squared also increases the negative
exponential will fall off
and so we obtain a shape of this kind
and symmetrically on the other side as
well and finally there is this constant
where does this constant is coming from
well there's a nice and not completely
straightforward calculus exercise that
tells us that the integral from minus
infinity to plus infinity of e to the
negative x squared over 2 DX is equal to
the square root of 2 pi now we need a
PDF to integrate to 1 and so for this to
happen this is the constant that we need
to put in front of this expression so
that the integral becomes 1 and that
explains the presence of this particular
constant what is the mean of this random
variable well x squared is symmetric
around 0 and for this reason the PDF
itself is symmetric around 0 and
therefore by symmetry the mean has to be
equal to 0 and that explains this entry
here how about the variance well to
calculate the variance you need to solve
a calculus problem again you need to
integrate by parts and after you carry
out the calculation then you find that
the variance is equal to 1 and that
explains this entry here in the notation
that we have been using let us now
define general normal random variables
general normal random variables are once
more specified in terms of the
corresponding PDF but this PDF is a
little more complicated and in the
involves two parameters mu and Sigma
squared where Sigma is a given positive
parameter once more it will have a bell
shape but this Bell is no longer
symmetric around 0 and there is some
control over the width of it let us
understand
the form of this PDF by focusing first
on the exponent exactly as we did for
the standard normal case the exponent is
a quadratic and that quadratic is
centered at X equal to MU so it vanishes
when X is equal to MU and becomes
positive L square then we take the
negative exponential of this quadratic
and we obtain a function which is
largest at X equal to MU and falls off
as we go further away from MU what is
the mean of this random variable since
this term is symmetric around mu the PDF
is also symmetric around mu and
therefore the mean is also equal to MU
how about the variance it turns out and
this is a calculus exercise that we will
omit that the variance of this PDF is
equal to Sigma squared and this explains
this notation here we're dealing with a
normal that has a mean of mu and the
variance of Sigma squared to get a
little bit of understanding of the role
of Sigma in the form of this PDF let us
consider the case where Sigma is small
and see how the picture is going to
change when Sigma is small and we plot
the quadratic Sigma being small means
that this quadratic becomes larger so it
rises faster so we get a narrower
quadratic and in that case the negative
exponential is going to fall off much
faster so when Sigma is small the PDF
that we get is a narrower PDF and that
will reflects itself in to the property
that the variance will also be smaller
an important property of normal random
variables is that they behave very
nicely when you form linear functions of
them and this is one of the reasons why
they're analytically tractable and
analytically very convenient here is
what I mean let us start with a normal
random variable with a given mean and
variance and let us form a linear
function of that random variable what is
the mean of Y well we know what it is
linear we have a linear function of a
random variable the mean is going to be
a times the expected value of x which is
mu plus B what is the variance of Y we
know what is the variance of a linear
function of a random variable it is a
squared times the variance of X which in
our case is Sigma squared so there is
nothing new so far but there is an
additional important fact the random
variable Y of course has the mean and
variance that we know it should have but
there is an additional fact namely that
Y is a normal random variable so
normality is preserved when we form
linear functions there is one special
case that we need to pay some attention
to suppose that a is equal to 0 in this
case the random variable Y is just equal
to B it's a constant random variable it
does not have a PDF it is a degenerate
discrete random variable so could this
fact be correct that Y is also normal
one will will adopt this as convention
when we have a discrete random variable
which is constant it takes a constant
value we can think of this as a special
degenerate case of the normal with mean
equal to B and with variance equal to 0
even though it is discrete not
continuous we will still think of it as
a degenerate type of a normal random
variable and by adopting this convention
then
we'll always be true that a linear
function of a normal random variable is
normal even if a is equal to zero now
that we have the definition and some
properties of normal random variables
the next question is whether we can
calculate probabilities associated with
normal random variables this will be the
subject of the next segment